Luke here at the outdoor boys YouTube
channel I'm going to show you how to
remove a tick and I'm going to review a
product called to take key okay this is
the product called the tick key it
claims it's 99.9% effective at removing
ticks and let me talk to you a little
bit about ticks here so ticks come in
different stages there's the larvae the
nymph and there's the adult male and the
larger adult females then when they get
engorged with blood after they've been
stuck on your blood they get even bigger
than that so there's a lot of different
sizes of ticks and here's the problem
the tick key doesn't work with the
nymphs and the larvas and the small text
which is usually what we get in my neck
of the woods and it's just the ticks not
big enough for the tick key to work you
slide it over the tick you try to pry it
up and it just doesn't catch because the
tick is too small spend about five
minutes trying to remove this tick and
it just wouldn't work no matter whether
I flip the tick key over or not just
wouldn't catch so just grip it between
your fingernails pull steady pressure
straight up and it just pops out you can
use the pair of tweezers instead if you
pull straight up the head doesn't come
off doesn't leave anything in the wound
nice and clean and all that burning the
tick out or putting nail polish remover
on it it's completely unnecessary so
pick key a bit of a failure only works
on big ticks so if you go to the CDC
website their recommendation on how to
remove ticks is to grab the tick as
close to the skin using tweezers or your
fingernails pull straight up away from
the skin with even pressure and then
wash the bite area in your hands with
some sort of sanitizer cleansing agent
that's it